spätes geständnis iran gibt zu das
ukrainische flugzeug abgeschossen zu
haben
demo gegen fass in kamp lintfort stellen
sich hunderte menschen hinter ihren
bedrohten bürgermeister und sprung ins
gelbe trikot mit seinem dritten
einzelsieg übernimmt karl geiger die
gesamt weltcup führung
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem samstag norbert lehmann ist auch
wieder dabei für den sport angelo namen
doch von mir
176 männer frauen und kinder starben
weil ein soldat die ukrainische
passagiermaschine für einen angreifer
hielt nach tagelangem leugnen hat der
iran nun doch zugegeben für den absturz
verantwortlich zu sein
allerdings machte der iranische
außenminister die usa und ihr so
wörtlich abenteurertum mitverantwortlich
für die katastrophe die menschen in iran
sind fassungslos aus teheran jörg brase
nieder mit den lügnern rahmen er soll
zurücktreten sprechchöre wütender
studenten vor der polytechnischen
universität in teheran am abend die
ukrainische linienmaschine abgeschossen
von der iranischen luftwaffe als sie
diese nachricht deutsche hörten platzte
vielen der kragen nach tagen der
ausflüchte und ist ein friedlicher
protest
wir wollen zeigen dass wir mit dem was
in den vergangenen tagen was jesus nicht
einverstanden was wir sind hier wegen
dem was die revolutionsgarden
angerichtet haben und wegen dem ganzen
anderen mist wir haben die nase voll
am vormittag hatte der luftwaffenchef
der revolutionsgarden in einer live
übertragenen pressekonferenz zugegeben
das nicht länger zu verheimlichen war
seine truppen seien wegen der
kriegsähnlichen situation am vergangenen
mittwoch schaden gespannt gewesen
ein luftabwehr offizier dachte das
objekt das ihm angezeigt wurde sei eine
amerikanische cruise missile
unglücklicherweise hatte eine hastige
entscheidung getroffen deswegen kann es
zu diesem schrecklichen unglück handy
videos im netz zeigen sogar den abschuss
der luftabwehr raketen
irans führung gestand den fehler ein
religionsführer ramin entschuldigte sich
bei den angehörigen der opfer
präsident johann i und außenminister
sarif kündigten die bestrafung der
verantwortlichen und hier
schädigung der betroffenen familien
kerzen für die opfer am abend in teheran
vielen der trauernden hier reicht die
entschuldigung ihrer regierung nicht aus
jörg brase in teheran bedeutet dieses
schuldeingeständnis für das land könnten
damit auch die regierungskritischen
proteste wieder aufflammen
also ich sag mal die beeindruckenden
bilder von regierungstreuen
massenaufmärschen nach der ermordung
general ceremonies die bedeuten ja nicht
dass die unzufriedenheit vieler mit den
herrschenden zuständen hier plötzlich
nicht mehr existiert aber das waren halt
nicht die tage für regierungskritische
proteste
die art und weise nun wie das militär
zum einen diesen vergeltungsschlag
glorifiziert hat aber auf der anderen
seite die verantwortung für den absturz
absturz der ukrainischen linienmaschine
abgestritten hat das hat doch viele hier
sehr sehr wütend gemacht jetzt erinnert
man sich natürlich an die blutige
niederschlagung der proteste vor zwei
monaten da sind ja viele hundert
menschen ums leben gekommen
und auch die demonstration heute abend
die wurde kurz nachdem wir dort gedreht
hat mit tränengas aufgelöst trotzdem
hören wir dass verborgen zu landesweiten
demonstrationen und trauer kundgebungen
aufgerufen wurde
vielen dank für diese einschätzung aus
teheran jörg brase es ist gut dass jetzt
klar ist wer für den absturz
verantwortlich ist das sagte die
bundeskanzlerin nach einem treffen mit
russlands präsident putin in moskau
iran müsse nun schonungslos aufklären da
war sie sich mit dem krimi chef einig
bei einem anderen krisenherd wollen
beide länder gemeinsam aktiv werden
unter dem dach der un soll in berlin
eine libyen konferenz stattfinden
christian senn berichtet
vom flughafen direkt in den kreml ein
kurzes treffen mit wladimir putin in
einer zeit in der die krisenherde in der
welt immer mehr werden
es geht um iran syrien die ukraine und
libyen
deutschland will im bürgerkrieg in
libyen vermitteln und eine
friedenskonferenz in berlin organisieren
es geht um nichteinmischung und
souveränität und deshalb sollten die
parteien die in libyen jetzt im
augenblick in einer militärischen
auseinandersetzung sind stellvertretend
will ich lernen herrn verrat und herrn
haft da auch natürlich engstens
beteiligt sein
seit 2011 herrscht bürgerkrieg in libyen
und russland steht in dem konflikt auf
seiten des einflussreichen generals
haffter an dessen seite russische
söldner kämpfen sollen
putin will die deutschen
friedensbemühungen unterstützen um den
konflikt zu beenden
all dies untergräbt nicht nur die
stabilität in der region sondern es hat
auch negative folgen für europa ich
meine die illegale einwanderung den
schmuggel den illegalen handel und die
verbreitung von waffen und drogen
russisches gas nach europa der bau der
gaspipeline nord stream 2 ist ins
stocken geraten us-präsident trump will
das projekt verhindern doch russland und
deutschland wollen die pipeline des
spätestens 2021 in betrieb nehmen wir
können die pipeline selbst zu ende bauen
ohne hilfe ausländischer partner
die kanzlerin sprach auch die sanktionen
gegen russland an wegen des ukraine
konflikts das deutsch russische
verhältnis bleibt sachlich wie nicht
herzlich doch angela merkel sagt es sei
besser miteinander zu reden als
übereinander
zu den wahlen nach taiwan der kleine
nachbar von china ist eine erfolgreiche
demokratie trotz des drucks aus peking
die chinesische führung betrachtet
taiwan als ihr eigen obwohl es nie zur
volksrepublik gehört hat hervorgegangen
ist taiwan aus dem großen bürgerkrieg
der 1949 endete chinesische kommunisten
hatten dagegen chinesische
antikommunisten gekämpft die
antikommunisten verloren zogen sich auf
die insel taiwan zurück dann die
wundersame entwicklung in wenigen jahren
wurde aus einer diktatur einer der
progressivsten staaten asiens dessen
bürger auch bei dieser wahl wieder ihre
unabhängigkeit demonstrieren
stephanie schöne baum freiheit
gleichheit und demokratie
dafür steht die fortschrittspartei und
dafür steht die wiedergewählte
präsidentin taiwans sei in mehr als acht
millionen teil werner wählten sie 57
prozent dafür dass sie sich von china
nicht einschüchtern lässt
sie ist aufgestanden und hat es china
klar und deutlich gesagt wir wollen
nicht ein land mit 2 system
taiwan ist nicht ein teil von china
noch am abend sendet eine botschaft nach
peking an den dialog gibt es nur auf
augenhöhe
ich hoffe china versteht dass eine
stabile entwicklung unserer beziehungen
von beiden seiten abhängt und die
verantwortung nicht nur auf einer seite
liegen kann
ihr herausforderer der konservative
hungry verlor auch weil seine politik
der offenen annäherung an china
viele abschreckte dieses wahlergebnis
wird peking nicht gefallen es ist eine
absage auch an die kommunistische partei
chinas die ihren druck auf taiwan immer
mehr erhöht die ansprüche auf dem
inselstaat erhebt und die forderung nach
einer vereinigung stellt im zweifel auch
mit gewalt taiwan will kein zweites
hongkong werden die angst davor hat 80
prozent der wahlberechtigten an die
urnen getrieben
taiwan hat sich für die demokratie in
seinem land entschieden
nach den wochenlangen streiks und
protesten in frankreich ruder die
regierung offenbar zurück mehrere
französische medien berichten dass
premierminister phillipe die erhöhung
des renteneintrittsalters auf 64 jahre
aus dem gesetzentwurf streichen will
wir kommen nach deutschland was
anfeindungen gegen kommunalpolitiker
auslösen können zeigt sich gerade in
nordrhein westfalen nach drohungen aus
der rechten szene hatte der
bürgermeister von kamp-lintfort den
großen waffenschein beantragt daraufhin
riefen rechtsextremisten für heute zu
protesten gegen ihn auf einige wenige
kamen und stießen auf hunderte von
bürgern die in die stirn boten dominik
müller
sie stehen hier für ihren bürgermeister
um ihm zu zeigen du bist nicht alleine
wir sind mit dir
ungefähr 1000 menschen aus kamp lintfort
und umgebung haben sich versammelt
ich bin zum beispiel aus krefeld
hierhergekommen nach kamp-lintfort und
ich finde es sehr wichtig dass wir hier
wirklich ein klares zeichen setzen ein
klares signal es darum geht dass wir
weiter frei leben können dass wir das
tun können was wir für richtig halten
und das alles aktie wurde dass die
buntheit als akzeptiert wird
100 mitarbeiter demonstrieren rund 20
anhänger der rechtsextremen partei die
rechte dagegen dass der bürgermeister
der stadt einen waffenschein bekommt den
hat der bürgermeister beantragt weil er
sich bedroht fühlt seit der im letzten
wahlkampf plakate dieser partei hat
abhängen lassen
auf der anderen seite ärgert es mich
besonders wenn das bedrohungsszenario
halt mit einer partei für die ich auch
arbeite in verbindung gebracht wird
ich bin mir sicher dass die parteien die
rechte nicht mit dem bedrohungsszenario
zu tun haben kann
der bürgermeister selbst ist heute nicht
hier er wolle nicht in texas manier
durch die straßen laufen teilte er
schriftlich mit habe aber mehrmals
bedrohungssituationen erlebt in denen
die polizei nicht rechtzeitig da gewesen
wäre wäre tatsächlich etwas passiert
speziell für diese konkret benannten
außergewöhnlichen notwehr situationen
habe ich den waffenschein beantragt um
angriffen gegen mich und meine familie
nicht schutzlos ausgeliefert zu sein von
waffen allerdings halten die menschen
bei der demo heute nichts
sie wollen deutlich machen dass so etwas
auch nicht nötig ist wenn die
gesellschaft ihre gewählten vertreter
nicht alleine lässt der windenergie in
deutschland geht gerade etwas die puste
aus der bau neuer windräder ist auf den
tiefsten stand seit 20 jahren gesunken
nach vorläufigen zahlen wurden 2009 10
nur 276 neue anlagen in betrieb genommen
im vergleich zum vorjahr ein minus von
mehr als 60 prozent
um den ausbau der windenergie gibt es
derzeit streit in der koalition ein
punkt dabei ist der mindestabstand zu
wohnhäusern
noch gut ein monat dann wird in hamburg
gewählt
zurzeit gibt es laut umfragen ein wahres
kopf an kopf rennen zwischen den
derzeitigen koalitionspartnern spd und
grüne die als stärkste kraft ins
prächtige hamburger rathaus einziehen
wollen die sozialdemokraten mit peter
tschentscher er wurde 2018 erster
bürgermeister als olaf scholz ins
bundeskabinett wechselte die grünen
hoffen mit katharina fegebank bisher
wissenschaftssenatorin ebenfalls auf
platz eins wie die beiden und ihre
verfolger in dem wahlkampf-endspurt
starten zeigt ralf zimmermann von
sievert er gibt sich kämpferisch
hamburgs erster bürgermeister peter
tschentscher die sozialdemokraten wollen
hier gegen den bundestrend für die
eigene partei und gegen den grünen
koalitionspartner die wahl gewinnen aber
wenn ich jetzt so höre wie stark die
grüne kraft nachdem bürgermeister am
strebt bin ich nicht sicher ob dort auch
abenteuerliche konzert konstellationen
plötzlich gewählt werden
jamaika und was wir alles in deutschland
haben insofern die beste entscheidung
klarheit zu bekommen über den kurs von
hamburg besteht darin spd zu wählen
die hamburger grünen also wollen die
führungsrolle übernehmen sehen mit
katharina fegebank dafür beste chancen
aber mir und uns geht es um die inhalte
und das ist der maßstab regieren ist
kein selbstzweck und auch das ziel erste
bürgermeisterin zu werden ist kein
selbstzweck es geht darum diese stadt
noch besser zu machen noch mehr aus ihr
herauszuholen
in allen umfragen deutlich zurück liegt
die cdu mit spitzenkandidat markus
weinberg der selbst keine chance auf das
bürgermeisteramt wir wollen am 23
februar die möglichkeit haben hamburg
mit zu gestalten dass es erstens wir
müssen rot grün durchbrechen und klar
sagen wir sind die partei der
bürgerlichen vernunft die freien
demokraten mit anna von treuenfels
hoffen auf ein zweistelliges ergebnis
und danach mitregieren zu können
er war als ziel ist dass wir tatsächlich
regierungsbeteiligung erlangen das ist
unser ziel wir möchten mit einem starken
ergebnis in die bürgerschaft die linke
mit cansu özdemir hingegen will gar
nicht in die regierungsverantwortung
sieht sich von vornherein in der
oppositionsrolle
spd und grüne sind nicht bereit mit uns
die armut in hamburg zu bekämpfen sie
sind nicht bereit einmieten der kellein
zu führen und mit der afg unter dirk
nockemann will auch in hamburg einer
regieren dennoch sehen sich die
rechtspopulisten weiter im aufwind
man will uns in eine bestimmte ecke
drängen damit wir nicht zu stark werden
ich kann all diesen bestrebungen oder
all diesen parteien nur sagen wir werden
in hamburg stärker die spannende frage
also bleibt im hamburger wahlkampf wer
hat die nase letztlich form von diesen
beiden peter tschentscher oder katharina
fegebank die die erste grüne
landeschefin in deutschland werden
könnte
wohin steuert der sozialstaat für die
linkspartei in die falsche richtung sie
fordert korrekturen etwa um auf
veränderungen am arbeitsmarkt reagieren
zu können
darüber hat der parteivorstand heute in
berlin diskutiert und über all dem steht
natürlich die frage wie kann die linke
damit bei den wählern punkten
cornelia schiemenz berichtet die linke
macht sich fit für die zukunft sie will
ein neues sozialstaats konzept motto der
sozialstaat braucht mehr als nur ein
update der braucht ein neues
betriebssystem um den herausforderungen
der zukunft gewachsen zu sein
das neue diesem konzept ist dass wir die
idee der sozialen sicherheit und der
sozialen garantien ganz eng verbinden
mit der idee dass wir eine soziale
infrastruktur brauchen und nicht
öffentliche daseinsvorsorge und
finanzielle leistungen gegeneinander
ausspielen
so möchte die linke eine anhebung des
rentenniveaus auf 53 prozent und eine
kindergrundsicherung in höhe von 600
euro
eine solidarische
gesundheitsversicherungen die alle
einzahlen
auch beamte und selbstständige und ein
120 milliarden investitionsprogramm in
bildung soziales und infrastruktur
sowohl für dieses 120
milliarden programm investitionen als
auch für die stabilität stabilisierung
der sozialsysteme würden wir eine
vermögenssteuer einführen würden wir den
spitzensteuersatz erhöhen und die
unteren er entlasten würde endlich eine
finanztransaktionssteuer eingeführt mit
ihrem sozialstaats konzept startet die
linke ins neue jahr ganz ohne streit
ganz anders als in früheren jahren
im süden indiens haben die behörden zwei
hochhäuser mit luxuswohnungen sprengen
lassen
die gebäude in kerala waren zu nah am
wasser gebaut
es ist eine der bisher größten abriss
aktionen aus umweltschutzgründen selbst
ein hungerstreik der wohnungseigentümer
konnte sie nicht verhindern
morgen sollen zwei weitere gebäude
gesprengt werden
wir sind beim wintersport norbert ein
guter tag für die deutschen athleten vor
allem für die die geiger heißen fangen
wir mit dem kahl an dem skispringer im
ersten weltcup wettbewerb nach der
vierschanzentournee holt der
oberstdorfer in val die firma seinen
ersten saisonsieg
die grundlage für seinen erfolg liegt
der oberstdorfer schon im ersten
durchgang als klar führender bestätigt
karl geiger mit diesen zweiten sprung
seine überragende form
103,5 meter auf der kleinen aufgrund
eines organisationsfehler es anstelle
der großschanze mit dem tagessieg
übernimmt er auch die führung im
gesamtweltcup hinter dem österreicher
kraft und den polen kuba ski und doch
springt der erst 20 jährige constantin
schmid auf platz 5 laie wird sechster
pasqua achter ja nun zum zweiten geiger
sieg der vom vinzens dem kombinierer
er gewinnt das duell mit dem
norwegischen topstar karl magnus reber
und rückt damit auf platz zwei in der
weltcup gesamtwertung vor
jubel bei vinzenz geiger über seinen
zweiten saisonsieg nach dem springen im
val die firma liegt der deutsche nur auf
platz 12 mit fast einer minute rückstand
auf seriensiegerin
wagnis lieber auf den zehn kilometern in
der loipe aber arbeitet sich geiger
stück für stück nach vorne und bezwingt
den norweger mit 0,4 sekunden vorsprung
dritter wird jürgen groh back ebenfalls
aus norwegen mit fabian rießle eric
frenzel manuel faißt und johannes rydzek
landen vier weitere deutsche in den top
ten platz drei für die deutsche männer
staffel beim biathlon heim-weltcup in
oberhof vor 23.000 zuschauern in der
rennsteig-arena hatte schlussläufer doll
vor dem letzten schießen sogar die
chance zum sieg weil die vorne liegende
norweger und franzosen federn ließen den
ersten fünf schuss mit einem fehler ist
gut mit zwei schwertern schon sehr hart
müssen wir ehrlich sagen am ende kam
sogar eine strafrunde zustande trotzdem
reichte es für das quartett horn käufer
dollar zum podestplatz hinter norwegen
und frankreich und die biathlon-staffel
der frauen die wurde vierter und eine
ehemalige biathletin ist gast im
aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr katrin
müller-hohenstein begrüßt die
siebenfache weltmeisterin laura
dahlmeier die ja ihre biathlon karriere
beendet hat ja um und am anfang einer
großen karriere stehen diese beiden
frauen laura nolte und deborah lee wie
die beiden hatten allen grund zum jubel
sie feierten heute in la plagne ihren
ersten weltcup sieg im zweierbob und das
in ihrem erst zweiten weltcup rennen
überhaupt und männer zweierbob
weltmeister francesco friedrich zusammen
mit alexander schüler ebenfalls gewonnen
aber ob die sich auch so schön gefreut
haben weiß ich nicht das wetter bleibt
ruhig im süden im norden gibt es regen
die details hat gleich erst intern
marietta slomka freut sich auf sie im
heute journal um zettel vor 11 und wir
danken ihnen für das interesse und
wünschen ihnen einen unbeschwerten
samstagabendshows und bis morgen wenn
sie mögen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter neuer regen kommt
aber erreicht er den norden deutschlands
ansonsten wird es eher trocken bleiben
veranlassen sie sehen hier die blauen
schlieren das ist der regen der sich
schon in der nacht im nordwesten
ankündigt und dazu gibt es auch
stürmische böen aus südwestlichen
richtungen nach süden hin klart es auf
und es bildet sich teilweise dichter
nebel und die temperaturen dazu gehen
bis auf minus 8 grad an den alpen zurück
nach osten hin gibt es auch noch
leichten frost bis minus 1 grad am
mildesten bleibt es an der nordsee mit
plus 5 grad morgen im süden dann sonnige
abschnitte aber der nebel da kann sie
auch länger halten und dann bleibt es
kalt nach nordwesten viele worten mit
regen und auch richtung ostsee und der
winter in der nordsee ist stürmisch aus
südwest die temperaturen wie gesagt im
nebel um null grad kalt sonst sind es
bis 10 grad im westen deutschlands
die nächsten tage am montag wird es
trocken sein aber mit vielen wolken bei
zwei bis zehn grad ja und am dienstag
kommt neuer regen bei 13 grad und
windiges wetter mittwoch sogar bis 16
grad
ein schöner abend